hey guys it's Eric I'm back this is
gonna be a painful video I really didn't
want to do this but I feel like I have
to I play the game earlier today it was
part of a bee chess tournament the the
chess postures prize arena and I was in
contention for first place I was in
second place behind the sky chess pot
spirit manizales and with about 15
minutes left in the tournament I was
maybe 10 tournament points behind and
then I had very upsetting somewhat
comical tragedy which I will go ahead
and show it was the last game I played
because I was just shell-shocked after I
played it so I'm gonna devote this video
to showing that game and show that bad
things happen to all of us sometimes
especially when you're caught off guard
or under estimating your opponent's so I
want to flip it to the game here I was
playing a fellow streamer let me see if
I can switch this scene I was playing
Joanna tries who's rated 915 I think
this game was probably her biggest win
ever and not only did she beat me she
beat me in 15 moves so I'm gonna show
the game hopefully except that I can't
undo the past and hopefully this will be
some sort of inspiration for the newer
players out there that miracles do
happen and and yeah okay so I was
playing pretty quickly I bezerk I was
trying to just win as quickly as
possible I played a pretty aggressive
opening some sort of Kings gambit and
then Knight f6 was played I was really
just focused on attacking and then she
plays this move d5 just makes things
really confusing in the center figured
why not take the
on e5 and then she played 97 I take the
pawn on d5 I was feeling pretty good at
this point
and after nights he takes e5 I wanted to
to just win as quickly as possible know
the way to try and win especially in the
speedgame is to just get all the pieces
into play rapidly so I played Bishop to
b5
she played c6 we trade made Bishop a4
queen e7 and then I Castle so at this
point I'm feeling pretty good I want to
play rook e1 target the e-file which has
a lot of juicy targets on it she takes
on f3 I was really happy to bring the
Queen and have a battery on that file
Queen c5 check was played King each one
95 Queenie 4 and already I was starting
to think like how do i eventually mate
the king or just win absurd amounts of
material I want to play d4 of course I
want to at some point win ce6 and win
this and like just when everything she
plays Bishop d6
I play d4 things are going according to
plan
she plays Queen c4 now I was thinking
move I could just take the free nights
and then I thought that maybe she
wouldn't see that I was attacking her
Queen discovered attack I was just
completely the wrong frame of mind given
that I had no sense of danger and after
Queen c4 black has a threat which I was
clueless about I took on e5 very quickly
and after the next move the game just
ended and then I was like confused for a
split second I took a few more seconds
for the realization to sink in that
Queen takes f1 is just game over my
clock was not defended my king were
still on g1 or my bishop developed it
would be different but Queen takes off
one was mates kudos
- Johanna for seeing this it seemed like
maybe this was a plan like when she
played even Queenie seven I don't know
if she was thinking this far ahead but
Queen c5 king h1 Queen c4 eventually
some it's one of these things which
despite the rating differential like
even when there is this case over can't
even do math over 1200 points between us
never underestimate anyone so might be
taking a break Fritjof from chess for a
while um maybe not I don't know I do
need a break after this game though I'll
probably recuperate for perhaps a day
and return with a more fresh state of
mind I want to show one thing if I go
full screen here and go to the
tournament thing people were
congratulating her in the chats but the
one we've comical thing if I go tall
towards the end of the standings and
trying to score I was one of her she had
what one - she had four victories in the
tournaments and I was one of her
victories so congratulations Joanna she
deserved the victory in this game and I
guess because she beat me
she indirectly beats Magnus Carlsen
which was pretty good life
accomplishments she's on the verge of
breaking a thousand I think she gained
what did she gain she gained 31 points
for this game ah people can see here 31
points I think that's all people want to
check out her stream I'll leave a link
in the description and I'll be back with
hopefully some happier games in the
future
see you guys